salamualikum' guys we got an amazing  show coming up soon we got a man who was  American or war veteran Desert Storm  Desert Shield but he took his hate of  Muslims to a whole new level  he was about to blow up a mosque but  innocent men women and children but  you're like what's he doing next to you  Eddie right now meet our forget our  brother Salam alaykoum how's everybody  out there just wanted to say peace and  love to the world and to all my Muslim  brothers and sisters thank you  coming up on a Dean show we got our  brother Richard the kidney coming up  soon stay tuned in here on the Dean show  from owning a blow-up ammas to accepted  Islam peace be with you Salaam alaikum